In reality, most studies of twins are
of twins raised together rather than in different
environments. But we can still estimate heritability
by comparing the concordance of a trait between
monozygotic and dizygotic twins even when they've
been raised in similar environments. So if a
pair of twins matches for a trait We
call it concordance. If they don't match then
we call it a discordance. The higher
the concordance for trait in monozygotic twins, compared
to dizygotic twins. Then the higher the heritability
of that trait. In other words, the higher
the match in monozygotic twins, when there's
a non-match in dizygotic twins, suggests that the
difference is the genetics, that the fact that
the monozygotic twins are identical, whereas dizygotic twins
are only half identical, right, they only share
50%. That being identical, those genes, those genetic factors,
are important in making the match. Alternatively, if
we found a lot of matching between monozygotic twins,
as well as a lot of matching between
dizygotic twins, because we know that there's the huge
difference in the genetic identity between these pairs
of twins that whatever's going on with the matching.
Likely has more to do with the environment
that the twins are raised in rather than
the fact that the monozygotic twins are identical.
Rather than genetics. For example, suppose you're interested in
handedness, right or left handedness. Taylor here is
left-handed and so is Grant. So they're concordant for
handedness. Now does this mean that handedness has
a high heritability? Why or why not? I want
you to think about this for a second, don't just
jump the gun and put something down. Think about the
question and then come up with what you think is
a good answer put it in the text box here.